I give Salam to my people in Bangladesh
Salam to the people of Marrakech
the second question that you ask is
about that you're good oh yeah so what's
the difference
yeah so what we see is that we believe
the Prophet Muhammad was a final
messenger so we affirm all the
messengers came we believe there was
thousands of them and they all came
through the same message yeah and that's
why sometimes you see in certain books
at the Hindu books of the back what he
does the Veda the Vedas
you would see that there's a
consummation even in the Bible
yeah you will see that there's always
this you know it's like something like
someone Hamid well you know Minh to the
Bible you always talk about for example
Jesus saying you know oh the father is
greater than I yeah I owe my own self
can do nothing as I see I judge and my
judgment is just because I do not seek
my own will but the will of my father
now anyone that says the will of my
father father god you're a Muslim we
don't fit him as a father
due to that we don't say you know it's a
rub so the thing is that we say that we
would respect the goulds
in the context of we have nothing back
against them what we see the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him has said that
he is like a lot of Hamilton he's a
final messenger now is there evidence
today so this is something that I was
researching when I first came to when I
was looking into Islam yeah so I would
feel to my so hold on a second let's put
this to the test you know how is it just
like comment I'm not gonna believe it
I'm sorry I'm a person where if I put my
head to something I'm gonna give my life
to it I'm not gonna give my life to any
like Tom Dick and Harry you get it and
I'm gonna come in like oh yeah this that
faith I saw a vision of your vision is
to yourself probably smoking crack or
something I don't know
do you get it so so the thing is I don't
know because some people have like mass
visions that oh we were sorry
it's that's subjective I can come and
say Islam is the truth because I came to
Islam
you know and it changed my life and it
made me a better person who worship
Satan can say the same thing yeah it's a
supporting argument but it's not a main
argument so the Prophet peace be upon
him one thing that really really stood
out and was very profound is that is the
Quran was Quran written by him yeah
now Allah subhana WA Ta'ala says if this
was from other than your Lord you will
find many discrepancies and
contradictions in it now that's an open
challenge for me that's like saying you
know what I'm challenging you yeah
imagine if I came and said you know so I
need the Libya I said the leap are not
how anybody in this whole brothel yeah
show me anyone except the sisters yeah
okay because there might be sometimes
you can knock me out
so I don't sisters think you guys Ostrom
I know you guys yeah so I thought this
guy you got bang unlocking my net boom
this guy everyone's going down and your
finger this guy's standing up to what he
said he's not just all talk yeah
the put a nice thing find something like
you and in other words Allah subhana WA
Ta'ala says bring a chapter like in and
the smallest chapter is what three
sentences three sentences so now to me
that's profound because what that means
is if somebody can do it the whole
Quranic argument is on the floor smashed
and then there's prophecies yeah unless
fanaticism so don't bully bedroom the
Romans have been defeated but they're
going to come back and win historians
say the way the Romans were defeated
them coming back at Kings janazah
straight you know janaza yeah you know
you bury him he's finished done he
started saying the Romans coming back is
a dream the Romans came back Allah says
in the Quran between three to seven or
three to nine years and they would
defeat the Persians that is a bold
statement if that doesn't come to be
brought we'll get mush up today there
will have someone here in the crowd
saying I'll look this didn't come to me
and the thing is there's so many of them
for example he talks about in history
talks about at the time of Joseph the
ruler a lot of panels are reversed him
as a king and at the time of Moses he
refers to him as a pharaoh so you know
why doesn't make that like why you know
King Pharaoh are they not the same thing
if you go to the Bible in the Bible it
refers to both of them as Pharaohs from
my mistaken Apophis kings yeah now this
is interesting because when they
decipher the hieroglyphics when they
discover the rosetta stone and they
decipher the hieroglyphics they they
found out he's a recording you say he's
he's my young bomber by the way yes he
accepted Islam but years ago
make dua for him yes it looks a bit like
me yes yes anyways so when you look at
it they discover the rosetta stone and
they decipher the hieroglyphics and they
found that at the time of Joseph the
rule is when I called Pharaoh they were
called Kingdom so coming into myself
y'all how does one know that and the
Prophet peace be upon me came with so
many prophecies prophecies / prophecies
there will come a time where barefooted
Edwin's he didn't say a nation
society was going to build high
buildings race with each other because
we can say you know the pyramids of
Babylon he says bare footed
Edwin's barefooted Bedouins yeah so now
we see in Dubai the tallest building
Mans racing with the other guys
the build is empty there's nothing that
they just reason to each other yeah so
the thing is over and over again he
talks about the Battle of Jumonville my
mistaken
he talked about how his wife will be she
would make a mistake and she would have
you know that talks certainly in her and
he would tell a little deal and to
forgive her so it's not specific and
every single one of them happened so you
think yourself out on a second how is it
that he's claiming things and his
character is current there was something
that need to call my attention because
it goes back to the whole statement that
he made his own enemies can you imagine
your own enemies that hate your guts
they want to see you dead but they say
this man sir
honest man I hate him I hope he died but
this guy's just on the spot and they
would give his belonging they belong you
know gold and stuff like that they'll
get him to look after it and he said to
them and this is what I found really
profound he said to them one day if I
was to tell you that's cause his people
would reject in him even though they
testified that he's the truthful if I
was to tell you there's an army coming
behind this mountain to come and kill us
would you believe me I said how could we
doubt you we know you to be truthful he
said I'm telling you I'm Lacoste
messenger because we will adjust it so
there's a lot of things there's a whole
book there's a book about it talks about
the signs as their judgment I would
personally say that anything that
complements Islam in the context or if
the girls for example believe in certain
things I think some cultures if I'm not
mistaken they believe the Prophet
Muhammad was a final master or something
along those lines I heard I'm not sure
I'm not really versed in it but the
thing is we respect that but however
what we say is unless is enough for em
and this goes to me because I come from
a family where my dad's agnostic my
mum's Alawis
yeah so from a cr6 yeah now I had a
choice like when when I came to Islam I
was you know my brother knows yeah I got
kicked out of the house yeah you know
these man's name is smoking he's bad
he's abused that yeah yeah so I'll go
keep that my house because I was called
what a traitor now the questions I need
to ask is this Allah says in the Quran I
even are you going to follow your
forefathers knowing that they were in
the wrong I had to be real with myself
when I look in the mirror I'm gonna say
to myself ok I don't get kicked out of
the house I just say you know what you
have to get Islam
and live like live a big life for the
rest of my life or say to myself you
know what if this is the truth and I've
done my research if that is the case and
I've looked at different religions and
different ideologies and philosophies
etc if there's evidence that this is one
God Almighty and I'm sincere and I ask
God I said God if you're that guy to me
whatever the prophecies the Bible ah go
to the Bible it's just whichever one I
don't mind because I'm seeking the truth
if you're genuinely looking for the
truth brava God will guide you and that
was my specific journey and I said you
know what I have to because even if the
whole world comes if they said you know
we're gonna hang you yeah
in that instance obviously we have a
stomach that you're allowed to lie that
yeah okay don't go man okay you know
when you say I'm trying say but I had to
be real and say look I'm sorry
respectfully to my dad that I'm sorry
but it's the truth unless you can prove
it wrong to me that if you can if you
can't then I'm sorry that you know and
being respectful to him and I believe if
you research into it more yeah that's
what it is and this we just believe is
final messenger we don't live in any
other messenger after that and yeah ask
your question